death of the American terrorists known
as the Unabomber two sources tell CBS
News Ted Kaczynski died by an apparent
suicide at a North Carolina prison
hospital on Saturday he was suffering
from late stage cancer for nearly two
decades starting in 1978 Kaczynski a
former math professor at the University
of California carried out a terror
campaign killing three people and
injuring 24 others with homemade bombs
he sent through the mill he was finally
found living in a 10 by 14 plywood cabin
in Montana after a tip from his own
brother in 1996. he eventually pleaded
guilty at the time of his death Kozinski
was serving four life sentences for his
crimes